>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
LAST YEAR CONGRESSIONAL
REPUBLICANS YOU REMEMBER PAST A
MAJOR TAX REFORM BILL.
IT ACCOMPLISHED A BIG GOAL FOR
THEM AND MANY OF THEIR DONORS.
A TAX REFORM WASN'T WHAT
REPUBLICANS RAN ON IN 2016.
POPULAR AS IT MAY BE NOW.
AT THE TIME THEY RAN YOU WILL
REMEMBER ON IMMIGRATION AND A
PROMISE TO TREAT AMERICA'S
BORDERS LIKE THEY ARE ACTUAL
BORDERS AND MATTER, LIKE THIS
WAS A REAL COUNTRY.
SOME REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS
THINK CONGRESS WANT TO BETRAY
THAT PLEDGE IN THE MOST DRAMATIC
POSSIBLE WAY.
THEY'RE WORKING TONIGHT TO PASS
A SO-CALLED DISCHARGE PETITION
IN THE HOUSE.
IT WOULD FORCE BOATS ON A SLEW
OF IMMIGRATION MATTERS,
INCLUDING SOME THAT WOULD GIVE
AMNESTY TO MILLIONS OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
HOW MANY?
WE CAN'T SAY BECAUSE WHEN YOU
PUSH ON THE NUMBERS A LITTLE BIT
IT TURNS OUT THAT NOBODY
ACTUALLY KNOWS HOW MANY ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS LIVE IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND WHEN WHEN WE SAY IT NOBODY
KNOWS, WE MEAN NOBODY KNOWS TO
WITHIN LIKE 10 MILLION.
THE ESTIMATE YOU HERE FOR ALMOST
EVERYONE IS 11 MILLION.
11 MILLION ILLEGAL ALIENS LIVING
IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT NUMBER COMES FROM PEW.
IT HASN'T CHANGED IN A DECADE
AND THAT SHOULD BE A TIP-OFF
BECAUSE OVER THE LAST DECADE
ILLEGAL ARRIVALS HAVE CONTINUED
AND NOW STATES ARE ACTIVELY
SABOTAGING DEPORTATION EFFORTS.
THE REAL FIGURE IT TURNS OUT IS
MUCH, MUCH HIGHER.
ICE DIRECTOR ADMITTED THAT MUCH
LAST YEAR.
WE KNOW 11 MILLION IS NOT
CORRECT.
SO WHAT'S THE REAL NUMBER?
AN UNPUBLISHED PAPER BY GALE,
THREE PROFESSORS THEIR ESTIMATES
THERE COULD BE 23 MILLION
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THEIR LOW-END ESTIMATE IS
17 MILLION.
EVEN BACK IN 2005, THE REAL
NUMBER WAS PROBABLY 20 MILLION
OR MORE.
AT THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY HOW MANY ARE HERE
BUT SOME MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS THINK IT IS A
GOOD IDEA TO GIVE AMNESTY TO
SOME OF THEM, OR MAYBE ALL OF
THEM.
IT'S NOT WITH THE VOTERS WANTED,
BUT THEY APPARENTLY DON'T CARE.
CONGRESSMAN JEFF DENHAM IS A
REPUBLICAN REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING OUT.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME BACK
AGAIN.
>> Tucker: SHOULDN'T WE FIGURE
OUT HOW MANY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ARE IN THIS COUNTRY BEFORE WE
ENCOURAGE MORE TO COME?
>> WHAT WE SHOULD DO IS ACTUALLY
SECURE OUR BORDER AND THE ONLY
WAY WE WILL GET THE BORDER
SECURED IS ACTUALLY WORKING
TOGETHER TO PASS SOMETHING OFF
THE FLOOR.
THE PRESIDENT CONTINUES TO TALK
ABOUT 25 MILLION AND SECURE
BORDER MAKING SURE THESE
CARAVANS AREN'T COMING ACROSS,
THE CATCH AND RELEASE PROGRAM.
THIS IS THE ONLY WAY WE ACTUALLY
BRING UP A DEBATE AND ACTUALLY
PUT SOMETHING ON THE PRESIDENT'S
DESK.
>> Tucker: WAIT A SECOND.
GIVING AMNESTY TO PEOPLE
ENCOURAGES MORE PEOPLE TO COME
HERE ILLEGALLY.
IT WAS TRIED IN 1986 AND THAT
WAS ITS EFFECT.
IT'S THE EFFECT EVERY SINGLE
TIME.
BEFORE WE GET MORE PEOPLE COMING
ACROSS AN BORDER SECURITY NOBODY
TAKES SERIOUSLY BECAUSE IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN A JOKE, WHY
SHOULDN'T WE KNOW HOW MANY ARE
HERE AND WHY DOESN'T CONGRESS
DETERMINED TO FIND OUT HOW MANY
ARE HERE?
IT SEEMS LIKE KIND OF A BASELINE
ISSUE.
>> RATHER THAN JUST DOING A
CENSUS TO FIGURE HOW MANY PEOPLE
HERE, WHY DON'T WE STOP THEM
FROM COMING HERE IN THE FIRST
PLACE?
DOING NOTHING MEANS ANOTHER
500,000 PEOPLE WILL CROSS OUR
BORDER EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
I'VE BEEN IN THE MAJORITY NOW
FOR EIGHT YEARS.
THAT'S 4 MILLION PEOPLE.
SHOULDN'T WE STOP RIGHT NOW AND
ACTUALLY DO WITH THE
PRESIDENT IS ASKING US FOR?
EVEN SOMETHING THE DEMOCRATS HAD
PROPOSED A FEW YEARS AGO AND
ACTUALLY PROVIDE THE FUNDING,
BUILD THE BORDER SECURITY, DO
THE SURVEILLANCE, MAKE SURE THAT
WE ACTUALLY HAVE A GUARANTEE TO
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC THAT WE'VE
STOPPED THIS INFLUX ACROSS OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> Tucker: HOW ABOUT THIS,
WOULD YOU SUPPORT PUNISHING ANY
EMPLOYER CAUGHT EMPLOYING AN
ILLEGAL ALIEN?
REALLY PUNISHING THEM.
CHECKING EVERY EMPLOYEE IN
AMERICA AND MAKING SURE THAT
NOBODY IS EMPLOYING ILLEGAL
ALIENS IN LIEU OF AMERICAN
WORKERS.
WHY NOT DO THAT STARTING, I
DON'T KNOW, TOMORROW?
>> AS YOU KNOW, AND A GOVERNMENT
PROGRAM, ESPECIALLY A NEW
GOVERNMENT PROGRAM THAT NEEDS
TECHNOLOGY DOESN'T START
TOMORROW.
I DO SUPPORT E-VERIFY.
I DO SUPPORT A COMPREHENSIVE --
>> Tucker: UNIVERSAL E-VERIFY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
BUT WE HAVE TO FIX THE REST OF
OUR IMMIGRATION PROCESS FIRST.
REPUBLICANS HAVE SET FOR QUITE
SOME TIME NOW WE WILL NOT PASS A
COMPREHENSIVE BILL, BUT YET
THAT'S WHAT      THAT'S WHAT'S B
THAT'S WHAT      THAT'S WHAT'S I
THAT'S WHAT      THAT'S WHAT'S G
PROPOSED TODAY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TALKED ABOUT
DEALING WITH BORDER SECURITY,
DEALING WITH OUR DREAMERS RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE THEY ARE IN A
DIFFERENT SITUATION AFTER
FOLLOWING THEIR GOVERNMENT AND
SIGNING UP FOR DACA.
WE NEED TO RESOLVE THAT ISSUE.
>> Tucker: FOLLOWING OUR
GOVERNMENT?
WE ENCOURAGE THEM TO COME HERE
ILLEGALLY WITH THEIR PARENTS?
>> NO.
IF WE HAD A PRESIDENT THAT
PASSED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER, WHICH
I DISAGREED WITH, BUT
NEVERTHELESS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES PASSED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT ALLOWED
DACA RECIPIENTS TO STEP FORWARD.
THESE KIDS WHO HAVE GRADUATED
FROM OUR HIGH SCHOOLS, WHO HAVE
GROWN UP IN THIS COUNTRY, WHO
KNOW OF NO OTHER COUNTRY OR NO
OTHER HOME, THEY'VE DONE WITH
THEIR COUNTRY HAS ASKED THEM TO
DO AND THEY'VE SIGNED UP FOR
THIS EXECUTIVE ORDER UNDER DACA.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE NOT
CITIZENS.
OKAY.
LET'S JUST BACK UP.
>> THEY'VE BEEN HERE FOR DECADES
>> THEY'VE BEEN HERE FOR DECADE
DECADES.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
I'M JUST SAYING IN A WORLD WHERE
THERE ARE A LOT OF PRIORITIES,
WHY IS THIS YOUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY?
IN YOUR STATE YOU GOT MORE THAN
100,000 PEOPLE LIVING ON THE
SIDEWALK, THOSE ARE AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
WHY DON'T YOU DEAL WITH A
PROBLEM LIKE THAT FIRST BEFORE
YOU START PASSING OUT
CITIZENSHIP TO PEOPLE HERE
ILLEGALLY?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
>> THE KIND OF AN ARGUMENT THAT
I GET FROM SOME OF THE LIBERAL
NETWORKS, WHY WOULD YOU HAVE A
PRIORITY OR THIS PRIORITY?
I BELIEVE ON ADDRESSING A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT ISSUES AT THE SAME
TIME.
>> Tucker: LOOK, GIVING
CITIZENSHIP AND VOTING RIGHTS TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE ILLEGALLY IS
NOT A WAY OF SECURING OUR
BORDER, SO WHY WOULDN'T YOU
SECURE THE BORDER FIRST?
>> WE HAVE TWO ISSUES THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS ASKED FOR,
INCLUDING HIS FOUR PILLARS, BUT
THE MAIN THING HE CONTINUES TO
TALK ABOUT, THE PRESIDENT ASKS
FOR A SOLUTION ON DACA AND FOR
BORDER SECURITY.
I BELIEVE THAT WE CAN GIVE HIM
BOTH.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
LET'S LEAVE THE PRESIDENT OUT OF
THIS.
IT JUST AS SOMEONE WHO IS HIRED
TO REPRESENT AMERICAN CITIZENS,
SPEAK SLOWLY SO I CAN
UNDERSTAND, WHY WOULD WE GIVE
CITIZENSHIP TO ANYBODY HERE
ILLEGALLY, GIVE VOTING RIGHTS TO
ANYONE WHOSE FAMILY CAME HERE
ILLEGALLY BEFORE NOT A SINGLE
NEW PERSON CROSSING THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY?
UNTIL YOU CAN LOOK YOUR VOTERS
IN THE FACE AND SAY OUR BORDER
IS SECURE, NOW WE CAN MAYBE GIVE
CITIZENSHIP TO ILLEGALS.
>> THAT DYNAMIC CHANGED UNDER
THE PREVIOUS PRESIDENT.
FIRST OF ALL, I DON'T BELIEVE IN
GIVING ANYBODY ANYTHING.
THIS WILL BE AN EARNED PATHWAY.
BY ALL OF THE DIFFERENT BILLS IT
WOULD BE AT LEAST A 10-12 YEAR
PROCESS.
FIRST SIGNED UP FOR FIVE YEARS
OF A TEMPORARY GREEN CARD THAT
WOULD ALLOW YOU TO WORK OR GO TO
SCHOOL OR SIGN UP FOR THE
MILITARY AND AT THE END OF FIVE
YEARS, AFTER YOU PASS THE
BACKGROUND CHECK, YOU HAVE PAID
YOUR FINE AND YOUR FEE, YOU'VE
ACTUALLY PROVEN THAT YOU ARE NOT
ON GOVERNMENT SUBSIDIES AND YOU
ARE OUT THERE WORKING OR GOING
TO SCHOOL OR SERVING YOUR
COUNTRY AT THE END OF FIVE
YEARS.
>> Tucker: NONE OF THAT'S
REAL.
>> WHAT YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT IS
ANOTHER FIVE YEARS, DOING IT ALL
OVER AGAIN, SO IT'S A 12 YEAR
PROCESS, TEN YEARS BEFORE HE
WOULD ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO GET A
LEGAL PERMANENT RESIDENT CARD.
>> Tucker: MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
WANT TO COME HERE.
WHY WOULD YOU GIVE A PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP FOR PEOPLE HERE
ILLEGALLY AHEAD OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE WAITING IN LINE, OBEYING OUR
LAWS?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
I'M CONFUSED I GUESS.
>> IT'S A 12 YEAR PROCESS AND I
BELIEVE THAT THIS EARNED PATHWAY
BELIEVE THAT THIS EARNED PATHWA
PATHWAY, THIS EARNED 12 YEAR
PROCESS WOULD PUT YOU AT THE
BACK OF THE LINE BUT CERTAINLY
SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN HERE, WHO'S
GRADUATED FROM OUR SCHOOLS THAT
HAS BEEN IN OUR COMMUNITY THAT
HAS FOLLOWED THE EXECUTIVE ORDER
UNDER OBAMA SHOULD HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
>> Tucker: OKAY I GUESS.
>> I DON'T GET AN OPPORTUNITY
JUST TO SIT BACK AND WAIT AND
SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> Tucker: AS A CONGRESSMAN
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA YOU GOT
A LOT OF PROBLEMS.
>> CALIFORNIA HAS A LOT OF
PROBLEMS.
YES.
>> Tucker: YEAH, YOU DO.
SO LIKE WHY WOULD THIS BE
ANYWHERE NEAR THE TOP OF YOUR
PRIORITY LIST?
I'M JUST COMPLETELY CONFUSED.
THESE ARE NOT AMERICAN CITIZENS.
TENS OF MILLIONS OF HURTING
AMERICAN CITIZENS IN YOUR
PUTTING THESE PEOPLE HAD OF THEM
AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT.
>> YOU ARE ELECTED TO LEAD AND
WE GOT TO DO SOMETHING ON THE
PRESIDENT CAMPAIGNED ON BORDER
SECURITY.
THE ONLY WAY WE ARE GOING TO GET
THAT, BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE RULES
OF THIS HOUSE AND THE SENATE,
YOU'VE GOT TO GET 60 VOTES.
THE ONLY WAY YOU'LL GET THE 60
MEMBERS ON A BIPARTISAN BORDER
SECURITY BILL IS WITH A SOLUTION
THAT IS EQUALLY AS IMPORTANT